[Musique]
bienvenue dans envies de lecture d'un
teddy wolf bonjour va essayer de
réfléchir un peu
une fois n'est pas coutume avec
indemnité exceptionnelle qui est un
philosophe c'est pierre henri tavoillot
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
philosophe je le disais vous enseignez à
la sorbonne à sciences po vous présidez
le collège de philosophie on vous donne
pas mal d'ouvragés qui occupent quelques
rencontres est d'ailleurs un très grand
public vous atteindre des uns de ces
philosophes voilà qui qui essaye de se
mettre à la portée du public on en
reparlera et vous voyez le traité de
nouveaux dark politique le guide
éthiques
pourtant incertain et on va parler
aujourd'hui de deux livres de votre
dernier livre qui s'appelle la morale de
cette histoire qui justement un livre
sur la morale et on va commencer peut
être par un livre qui est paru l'année
dernière chez odile jacob comment
gouverner un peuple le roi qui est une
année c'est une réflexion sur la
démocratie
oui c'est en effet sur le sur lequel
vous interrogez vous interrogez le
déclin démocratique
on va y revenir mais d'abord car henri
tavoillot qu'est ce que c'est que la
démocratie
vous vous rappelez dans les premières
phases de votre livre là la fameuse
formule de lincoln qui disait que la
démocratie c'est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple et pour le peuple
et d'ailleurs ce peuple est ce qu'on
peut déjà le définir ce peuple que
certains prétendent incarner
oui c'est le grand défi cette définition
est sublime d'ailleurs nous l'avons
incorporé nous mène dans notre
constitution francon que c'est dire si
elle est belle mais c'est pour une fois
que l'effet d'admiration est passé on
est un peu plongé dans l'incertitude
parce que elle pose deux énigmes
colossal d'abord c'est quoi le
gouvernement
et puis encore plus abyssal c'est quoi
le peuple
donc je vais laisser de côté la première
mais c'est vrai que le peuple on est
souvent tenté de continuer que c'est
évident on sait très bien ce qui serait
que je sais ce que c'est que le peuple
on va le chercher dans la rue etc
on commet n'arrive pas à le trouver en
général on
va rechercher des ennemis du peuple
c'est souvent beaucoup plus facile en
disant que si on sait contre qui on est
on va pouvoir parvenir à s'identifier
ça ne marche pas non plus alors à la fin
de cette processus on va aboutir à
l'idée que l'on va faire confiance à
quelqu'un qui nous dit le peuple ce
témoin voilà et puis on va être de
nouveau déçu ça repart pour un tour
mais justement quand 16h10 le peuple
c'est moi il ya quand même une partie du
peuple qu'il est qui les croient oui ça
dure jamais très longtemps il faut il
faut bien être
bon ça peut faire beaucoup de dégâts
mais c'est une pioche à un air très
longtemps donc c'est un peu la démarche
qui m'a animé dans ce livre s'est
éveillée bon bah ils font quand même
affronté cette question parce que si on
est en démocratie
si on règle pas le problème de savoir ce
qu'est le peuple et donc l'idée de base
qui structurent nos démocraties
libérales c'est que le peuple à une
figure pluriel savez pluralité peuple et
mais il faut les articuler ensemble
parce que si on considère que le peuple
ait un
alors là on risque vraiment d'aller du
côté de du totalitarisme si je puis dire
c'est le côté fusionnelle et donc le
peuple à trois visages pour le dire très
rapidement le peuple c'est d'abord ce
qu'on appelle la société cdr des
individus qui tissent ensemble des liens
qui vivent ensemble comme on dit mais ça
ne suffit pas pour faire le peuple il
faut suffit pas de vivre ensemble il
faut aussi vouloir vivre ensemble et
donc ce à côté de ce pack la société il
ya le peuple et état et puis ça suffit
pas encore pour faire une voix un vrai
peuple de la démocratie il faut pas
simplement vivre ensemble vouloir vivre
ensemble mais il faut discuter de la
manière dont on veut vivre ensemble et
ça c'est le peuple espaces publics dont
déjà on a trois figures du peuple c'est
vrai que les penseurs libéraux initiaux
considéré que l'articulation fluide
entre ces trois peuples à lèvres bien
faire fonctionner la démocratie
or il faut bien constater que ce n'est
pas le cas parce que chacun de ces trois
peuples a envie de boucher les deux
autres pour le dire un peu vulgairement
et donc j'essaie de proposer l'idée d'un
quatrième peuple voire d'un cinquième
peuple mais qui serait en fait la
synthèse et je résume sa d'une phrase en
fait là il faut changer un peu d'états
d'esprit le peuple c'est pas un visage
qu'on va rencontrer
c'est une méthode c'est une manière de
vivre comme
et cette méthode correspond à quatre
éléments d'étapes 4 étapes de cette
méthode il faut des élections il faut de
la délibération il faut des décisions on
oublie un peu et il faut rendre des
comptes
voilà ces quatre éléments sont les
piliers de la démocratie il ya un peuple
de la démocratie quand on respecte de
manière articulée proportionnée c4
bonbons là on est sûr qu'on est en
démocratie non manque un on n'est pas en
démocratie
d'ailleurs vous vous disiez à l'e3 les
trois peuples donc la société l'état de
l'opinion
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
souvent quand on parle du peuple où on
privilégie le dernier à se dire
l'opinion à ce que ce que les sondages
et cetera le peuple veut que etc alors
on reparle justement de cette démocratie
vous dites aux phocéens système qui
assez décevant et comment pourrait-il ne
pas l'être parce qu'il nous promet la
liberté d'égalité de fraternité et
accessoirement l'approprient la
prospérité et le bonheur est évidemment
on va être toujours déçu dans un régime
qui qui qui promet tout ça au fond la
démocratie elles sont sujettes à deux
reproches un peu contradictoire soit on
leur reproche d'être impuissante
soit on leur reproche d'être trop
autoritaire et comment ils peuvent jouer
entre ces deux reproches très
contradictoires oui vraiment le point
important de souligner ici c'est que la
démocratie est un résident déceptif
c'est à dire qu'elle nous promet
beaucoup
elle nous promet notamment que chacun
sera maître de son destin
bon c'est un peu le mythe de la
toute-puissance et c'est vrai que dans
les mouvements populistes que l'on
pourra aujourd'hui très important de
noter que ces mouvements populistes ne
sont pas des fascismes comme on le
pensait par le passé mais ce sont plutôt
des hypers démocratie cnrd
on critique la démocratie au nom de ses
promesses avec l'espoir qu'on arrivera
une démocratie parfaite
je pense que le grand défi du
contemporain c'est de se dire que c'est
ça être adulte c'est le monde va
toujours un petit peu nous déçoit
revoilà il va bouder soir n'aura pas
d'égalité il y aura pas parfait tuera
pas de liberté par fêtera pas de faire
taire ni départ fait le bonheur n'est
pas totalement accessibles donc il faut
partir de cette déception au lieu d'en
arriver là ça c'est vraiment la grande
transformation à venir
effectivement comme vous le disiez dans
démocratie est à la fois des mosses le
peuple et kratos et il faut plus deux
marchent ensemble c'est à dire que si
vous avez un peuple mais sans aucun
pouvoir
ça produit une catastrophe parce que le
peuple ne sera pas maître de son destin
et si vous avez un pouvoir sans le
peuple du coup ça créera une dictature
dirigée ou autoritaires donc la
démocratie libérale et notre régime doit
tracer son chemin entre ces deux écueils
ces 2 tentation plus de pouvoir à des
peuples bizarre qui vont se diviser qui
ont fait des individus et donc ça sacre
allemand les choses ou alors plus de
puissance d'agir mais au risque
effectivement de mettre en péril les
libertés alors il ya aussi dans les
démocraties ce qu'elles rencontrent
aujourd'hui c'est aussi une crise on le
voit bien des partis politiques d'aidé
des élus une crise de la représentation
est l'une des solutions aujourd'hui
c'est le recours à ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie directe avec cssa semblé
tirer hausse vous êtes très opposées
alors pourquoi vous y êtes opposé d'une
pareille mais quand même
est-ce que vous reconnaissez qu'il peut
y avoir une crise de la représentation
et donc de la démocratie
alors il y a une crise d'une aux
sentiments de représentation mais qui
vient plutôt de la montée en puissance
de notre exigence plutôt que des défauts
du système je veux dire par là que nous
disposons aujourd'hui de moyens
d'information énorme ça vous prêt à
donner notre avis sur tout grâce aux
réseaux sociaux et donc d'une certaine
façon
forcément quand on regarde les choses
décisions qui sont prises pour une bonne
part d'entre elles nous serons en
désaccord
voilà donc est ce que sait faire rendre
service à la démocratie que de dire il
faut que chaque individu et son petit
droit de veto personnel non parce que
évidemment on oublie l'intérêt général
donc c'est si on est vraiment dans une
situation disons la halle à
l'augmentation de l'espace public
produits paradoxalement plutôt de
l'impuissance publique
de l'efficacité alors si je suis
effectivement plutôt défavorable la
notion de démocratie participative
d'abord c'est parce qu'elle est très
flou on sait pas exactement ce que ça
comporte fait plein de réalité est ce
que c'est ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
délibérative
est ce que c'est la prise de décision
est ce que c'est le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne est ce que c'est
ce qu'on appelle le we call c'est à dire
l'idée qu'on pourrait virer les élus dès
lors qu'on qui nous ne s'attirent toute
une série d effectuer un contrôle
continu maintenant on fait passer du
comme pour le bac du contrôle au liban
voix la face est un peu dont j'aimais
plus profondément je pense que le grand
danger de la démocratie participative
voilà je vais je dis de manière très
simple c'est moi j'adore la politique
jeu
j'écris je me passionne pour ces
questions mais de là à passer toutes mes
soirées dans des assemblées qui
déciderait des affaires publiques
non voilà je vais pas y aller je préfère
avoir un bon match de foot
un film est donc si moi je ne sais pas
si on a un régime de démocratie
participative qui va y aller alors deux
catégories et ceux qui ont le temps donc
la démocratie participative c'est un peu
la dictature de ceux qui ont le temps et
puis par ailleurs et bien des militants
c'est à dire ceux qui sont vraiment
qu'ils passent leur vie à ça donc au
lieu de dire ça va augmenter le pouvoir
du peuple
je considère que ça va usurper le
pouvoir du peuple si l'on crée ses
institutions
voilà donc je trouve qu'il ya un
dessaisissement et je préfère de
beaucoup à voir des hommes politiques
des élus que je peux contrôler que je
peux virer après leur mandat
on ne put votant pour eux plutôt que
d'avoir des individus que je ne connais
absolument pas et qui vont peu à peu
prendre le pouvoir
toutes les expériences de démocratie
participative au-delà du caractère
enthousiasmant du début on est tous très
contents c'est génial on va discuter
puis au bout d'un mois plus personne
lima c'est totalement déserté et s'il ne
reste que les militants dernière
question peut-être son agression la
démocratie il ya eu ces événements du
capitole que tout le monde a suivi
ce que c'est l'amérique c'est considéré
traditionnellement comme la plus grande
démocratie moderne du monde
est ce que on n'a pas eu ce sentiment un
peu fou que les démocraties était
inattaquable
est ce que finalement elles sont pas
plus fragile qu'on ne le pense elles
sont à la fois très forte et très
fragile l'argument de la faiblesse des
démocraties est un vieillard du monde
donc voir avec ceux des régimes
impuissant d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant parce que les démocraties
sont plutôt faibles en temps calme mais
en période de crise les choses remette
un peu dans les clous en fait elles
témoignent d'une certaine grande une
forme de résilience dans les phases de
crise mais ce qu'on a soi qu'on a
assisté c'est effectivement totalement
sidérant c'est à dire que la plus grande
démocratie
la première démocratie à vrai dire du
monde a failli sur deux points c'est à
dire que un loyer si on reprend le
peuple méthode que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure élections délibération décision
reddition de comptes et la reddition de
compte ça veut dire rendre le pouvoir et
vous avez là le président de la plus
grande démocratie qui dit je ne prends
pas pouvoir jauger pas très envie de me
rendre tout ça a échoué et doit
continuer d'exister
il n'y a pas eu de coup d'état ou de
révolution et puis le 2e pilier
c'est un le monde électoral c'est-à-dire
le vote
et là vous avez un président élu toute
une partie de la population qui a dit eh
bien en fait nous n'avons plus confiance
dans notre système électoral donc la
démocratie américaine reste formellement
juridiquement tout à fait stable
l'existant n'y a pas de rupture mais et
les fragilités zay à la fois sur le
moment électoral plus de confiance dans
ce système électoral et sur le deuxième
moment de la reddition de compte on ne
rend pas le pouvoir on est tenté de ne
pas le rendre que oui il faut être
prudent grande force parce que c' est
capable dans les situations de crise
d'offrir une image
oui puissante forte et faiblesse parce
que c'est un régime compliquer la
démocratie un démocratie c
pardon c'est pas fait pour les nuls
c'est très compliqué on a l'impression
que c'est évident c'est en vérité très
difficile à comprendre un mot quand même
parce que il ya aussi et ça change
peut-être la façon de gouverner il ya
les chaînes d'info continue d'ailleurs
qui font des événements constant et puis
il ya les réseaux sociaux ça aussi est
ce que ça ne change pas ou font la
manière de gouverner peut-être la
démocratie oui c'est un point qui est
assez récent alors je serais assez
malgré tout optimiste sur la question ça
que nous avions nous étions convaincus
que les réseaux sociaux d'abord c'était
une très bonne chose pour la démocratie
parce que ça créait d'une certaine façon
comme une agora en fait une espace
public libre ouvert où toutes les
opinions pouvait se dire vous pouvez
potentiellement décider ensemble donc il
ya une grande naïveté
au départ lorsque l'internet est arrivé
on va dire internet pas régénérer la
démocratie et enfin nous allons aller
vers la démocratie directe
on est sortis de cette naïveté
manifestement on a vu qu'un espace
public ouvert aux quatre vents et bien
était extrêmement fragile par rapport à
des déstabilisation massive qui donnait
soit de l'étranger ça d'ailleurs de
notre propre pays et donc que ça
fragilise et vous alors là où on peut
être malgré tout un peu optimiste c'est
que je d'abord la prise de conscience a
eu lieu très rapide en l'espace de 5 6
ans l'espèce de d'illusions et de
naïveté a disparu on est désormais très
attentif
on envisage des mesures de régulation
alors je suis pas très favorable à ce
que un gars fa des sites comme ça de
clore le compte d'un président américain
sa part est effectivement très très
troublant parce que c'est pas
démocratique c'est une décision
unilatérale mais en même temps on peut
envisager des mécanismes
d'autorégulation ou de régulation en
faisant en sorte que par exemple les
directeurs de plateformes soit
responsable du contenu hl qui est
diffusée sur leurs patins responsable
juridiquement et puis par ailleurs vous
avez des schémas d'autorégulation j'ai
été très frappé au moment de la crise du
confinement
de voir la manière dont les médias à
autorités c'est à dire avec une marque
rené un peu en force par rapport aux
médias qu'ils ont alternatifs comme
mondiale une marque c'est important
parce que ça veut dire que vous avez des
interlocuteurs le suggère le journal le
figaro le monde libération etc
peu importe mais vous avez des des
personnes des visages et dans des
périodes où la formation est très
douteuse
en fait on je crois est tenté malgré
tout de revenir au mark
si le discours alternatif a toujours
vendu aujourd'hui alors nathalie on va
parler de deuxième livre de pierre henri
tavoillot la morale de cette histoire
alors qu'il lui est chez michel lafon
seuil est amusant maillard hier 10
livres c'est odile jacob du jacob est
plutôt là l'éditrice des universitaires
michel lafosse d'un éditeur plus
populaires c'est d'une façon pour vous
de dire qu'il faut s'adresser à tout le
monde
oui c'est en fait on ne pense pas
souvent comme ça mais c'est très très
difficile de décrire pour tout le monde
c'est vraiment un exercice encore plus
difficile et j'essaye effectivement de
me livrer de plus en plus à cet exercice
et l'air de faire en sorte que d'aller à
l'essentiel ont enlevé l'échafaudage des
travaux d'un travail qui équiperont je
veux pas faire mon je vais pas me
plaindre mais d'un travail qui est
toujours très important mais mais
d'essayer effectivement de d'aller à
l'essentiel et de s'exprimer tenir un
peu une manière claire accessible par
tous les voilà mais bon je suis pas
encore totalement arriver mais si je
joue j'ai déjà vu quand tu veux te tuer
les lecteurs nathalie alors oui
justement dans ce box est un livre dans
lequel on va parler du retour de la
morale qu'on appelle aujourd'hui et
higuain pour pour ne pas la nommer donc
c'est le sujet de votre livre d'abord on
parle volontiers des tic aujourd'hui
plus difficilement de morale qui est un
côté peut-être un peu plus sur année
donc pourquoi la morale at-elle mauvaise
presse
alors en fait c'est très compliqué parce
que au fond je fais pas de distinction
entre éthique et moral
c'est grave et morale c'est latin on
peut en faire entre les deux certains
m'ont fait mais rien ne nous y oblige et
simplement ça révèle quelque chose de
notre temps présent c'est à dire que
pour une part nous sommes tous des vieux
réac prêt à dire là les valeurs d'antan
tout ça à 10 points ou plus il ya plus
de morale ça c'est le premier aspect pic
de l'autre côté nous sommes tous des
enfants de mai 68 en disant si quelqu'un
vient nous imposer une un ordre moral de
l'extérieur qui concernerait tous les
éléments ne dit on va dire complètement
tchad a surtout pas je nous sommes à
l'âge de tutu choix moral et puis
troisième élément de cette crise quand
même le sentiment que quelque chose
comme un ordre moral est en train de
revenir
voilà donc par exemple il ya des choses
que vous ne peux pas dire si si vous
dites vous parler avec quelqu'un en
disant qu'il est noir vous allez être
accusé de racisme
si vous parlez de si vous offrez une
poupée à une pour noël une jeune fille
enfin enfants oui attention vous allez
faire le jeu du patriarcat et donc il ya
un ordre moral qui est aussi en train de
re si vous mangez une autre cote alors
là je ne raconte pas de moralisation du
monde qui arrive donc on a un paradoxe
du moral à la fois opéré pénurie crise
morale et on excès et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait arriver à résoudre c'est le
projet du livre la morale jusqu'à place
et si possible moins de chance oui c'est
ça et d'ailleurs vous vous posez la
question finalement comment en
démocratie est bien obéir à des
principes moraux qui ne viennent que des
hommes c'est une question intéressante
aujourd'hui parce que on est confronté
aussi à des questions inédites
on a question du progrès de la biologie
la question d'intelligence artificielle
des robots peut-être l'homme augmenté
qui pourrait même selon certains devenir
immortel sincères vont quand même assez
compliqué la question de savoir où se
trouvent les biens où se trouve le mal
alors oui et non c'est à dire que
pour une part nous avons effectivement
nous sommes confrontés à ce que
j'appelle des territoires desquels les
territoires nouveaux de l'éthique sur
lesquels les morales traditionnelles
n'ont rien à nous dire par exemple sur
la question environnementale pour un
philosophe ancien l'idée de protéger la
nature c'est juste ça n'a aucun sens si
aucun sens vers la nature c'est ce qui
est fait ternel pour un philosophe
ancien c'est tout mais tous croient tout
meurt et s'il ya une chose qui ne change
pas c'est bien ça c'est que tout change
donc l'idée d'une protection de la
nature n'a aucun sens voilà un domaine
totalement nouveau l'idée de manipuler
le vivant humain de l'augmenter de
changer de faire la bonne naissance ou
la bonne mort voilà quelque chose qui
est tout à fait neuve l'idée thème de
l'intelligence artificielle et ses
conséquences éthiques
on est des territoires nouveaux et donc
c'est ça qui est nourri une sorte de
panique éthiques
c'est à dire que nous le sommes tous ont
le sentiment que les progrès de la
science et la technique de la maîtrise
humaines vont beaucoup plus vite que
notre aptitude à les apprivoiser d'un
point de vue éthique ça c'est l'élément
de la crise mais d'un autre côté il faut
admettre que en matière de morale les
principes sont parfaitement claires
contrairement à ce qu'on dit nous avons
trois principes d'une clarté absolue ils
n'ont pas changé depuis 6000 ans même
par rapport au relativisme éthique
qu'elle est un peu à la mode ces
principes éthiques
il existe partout dans tous les temps
premier principe ne fais pas à autrui ce
que tu ne vois pas pourquoi chiffres
indienne pti ne laisse pas faire à
autrui ce que tu ne voudrais pas
construit face à foix ou à des proches
et puis troisième principe pas si
possible faire à autrui ce que tu
devrais contre 8,1 cette fois ou à tes
proches voilà là dessus aucune morale ne
prêche contre ces 3 1 ce type qui donne
une stabilité parfaite mais justement
alors je me pense que designer talibans
prenaient aux problèmes concrets par
exemple celui de la gestation pour
autrui la gpa
vous avez deux positions totalement
opposées yade a qui disent c'est
formidable parce que ça va permettre à
des gens qui ne pouvaient pas en avoir
d'avoir des enfants est sans doute de
les aimer profondément
et puis d'autres comme sylviane
agacinski qui dit mme o finalement 7e
c'est une
une aliénation du corps des femmes d'une
sorte d' esclavage moderne et moralement
les deux positions sont soutenables
qu'est ce que nous apprend la banque est
ce que nous dit la morale c'est un
problème très concret comme ça alors
peut-être d'abord d'identifier que c'est
pas forcément un problème moral
c'est-à-dire les débats des valeurs qui
sont extérieurs ceux qui disent il n'y a
rien de supérieur à la vie la vie est
sacrée spa et spa graphiquement ça c'est
un principe métaphysique et ceux qui la
liberté est sacrée et donc le débat ici
n'est pas moral il est plutôt
métaphysique la question morale c est ce
qu on lui s conduit à quelqu'un ou est
ce qu'on ne lui parce qu'on peut lui
faire du bien la question c'est est une
question très difficile il ya une
nuisance fait à l'égard de l'enfant à la
carte de la femme l'égard de la famille
mais la famille concrètes et pas la
famille en général donc le ferai la
vraie question morale c'est la question
de la nuisance
or nous confondons aujourd'hui des
questions éthiques et des questions
métaphysiques des choix métaphysique et
des choix éthiques d'où la confusion
d'où la confusion ou la très grande
difficulté et c'est sur cette question
là c'est emblématique puisque les les
bouleversements technologiques sur ce
qu'on appellerait l'eugénisme
c'est le sens étymologique c'est comment
bien-être et puis l'euthanasie c'est
comment bien mourir noyé le bourg entre
philosophique des mots ont bien changé
eh bien ces questions là sont des
questions qui nous passionne à la fois
parce qu'on nous sommes tétanisés mais
qui sont des passes des questions qui se
dépasse assez largement la morale oui il
n'ya pas de morale sans votre hui
d'ailleurs autrui c'est une vous
interroger dans des pages passionnantes
dans dans votre livre parce que autrui
ça peut être les autres hommes ça peut
être
peut-être les robots je ne sais pas les
animaux la nature si on prend l'exemple
des animaux on voit bien qu'il ya une
évolution dans la façon dont dont les
hommes inflige un certain nombre de
traitements aux animaux on supporte de
moins en moins mal
par exemple la violence dans les
abattoirs dont les dans les élevages de
poulets hors sol on a vu que l'animal a
changé de statut juridique ans et plus
un meublé le code civil récemment la
halle a consacré en tant qu'être
sensible alors est ce que cette
évolution doit aller jusqu'à
l'antispécisme qui considère qu'il ya
pas de différence entre l'homme et
l'animal
personnellement je suis très réservé à
l'égard de cette évolution qui la loi
tocqueville un bateau qu'il s'est vidé
que la démocratie c'est à dire l'idée
d'égalité s'est peu à peu élargi ses
idées par autrui c'était juste les gens
de mon village où ma famille puis après
les gens de ma région puis après les
gens d'une manne à sion et les autres
les étrangers étaient guère autrui on
est arrivé à une situation de stabilité
ou une dizaine grosso modo autrui ce
sont les humains jusqu'à ce que on
élargit encore le cercle en dix ans et
fille ont réduit mais est ce que les
animaux les robots les générations
futures les vivants les morts et c est
ce que les plantes les rochers ne serait
pas aussi d autrui sans parler des
extraterrestes à venir j'ai plutôt de la
réticence à l'égard de l'extension du
domaine de l'autrui si vous permettez
cette expression notamment aux animaux
avec cette formule qui consisterait à
dire nous avons des devoirs envers les
animaux et les animaux n'ont pas de
droit pourquoi l'argument il me semble
très simple c'est que si nous faisons de
l'animal à mettre moral ça veut pas
simplement dire que nous comportons bien
avec lui ça veut dire que
potentiellement cet animal peut être
considérée comme méchant la morale c'est
pas simplement d'être gentil c'est aussi
la possibilité d'être méchant et ça qui
fait la morale et si nous nous
considérons qu'il animal peut être
méchant si je sais qu'il existe des
chiens méchants mais c'est du par
analogie
ça veut dire qu'on va faire porter sur
les animaux un poids de responsabilités
qui me paraît peu compatible avec leur
protection
donc je trouve que les défenseurs des
droits des animaux
en fait sont ici en contradiction avec
eux mêmes ils vont faire porter des
responsabilités aux animaux
au lieu de simplement les protéger comme
ce que disait michelet des frères
inférieurs ou des frères d'en bas la
sollicitude s'adresse à des gens
d'affaires
pardon à des animaux qui sont et qui
sont dans bye les gars on a le droit de
la sollicitude sans parler de
l'extraordinaire variété du terme animal
qui va je le rappelle de l'eponge au
bonobo le bien-être d'une huître si vous
voulez c'est encore à discuter voilà
écouter alors on va renvoyer vos livres
pas ce concours au quotidien avec
plaisir encore pendant pendant une heure
ou deux avec vous mais j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion de leur faire des
conversations des émissions avec vous je
rappelle voilà votre dernier livre donc
c'est la morale de cette histoire guide
éthique pour dans un certain c'est chez
michel lafon
et puis le l'autre livre dont on a parlé
qui est une livre de philosophie sur la
démocratie c'est comment gouverner un
peuple le roi traité nouveaux dark
politique c'est chez odile jacob
merci infiniment pierre henri tavoillot
merci nathalie vol
[Musique]